do you think there are more porn stars  or murderers in the world if our  definition of porn star includes just  anybody who's ever had an only fans or  maybe like sold a photo then for sure  porn star but if we're talking like  actual like real porn stars who have  shot for a real company i think you have  to think like the percentage of people  who have killed someone in america is  probably so low compared to a lot of  other countries so i think for sure and  there's probably almost nobody doing  porn in a lot of those countries too so  porn is one thing that almost nobody  gets to keep a secret and a murder  ideally you get to keep a secret yeah